I told you about six weeks ago that the Trump
administration's then new strategy on the
virus would be to pretend the virus has been
fixed.
We are past the peak.
They were saying they're not going to do any
more press briefings with doctors.
Very little talking about the virus or treatments
or vaccines.
They'll instead focus on reopening the economy,
restaurants, recovery, all of that stuff.
And that's exactly what happened.
And meanwhile, as I already told you earlier,
cases have exploded in places like Florida,
which is hitting higher and higher new highs
in terms of cases every day.
Places like Texas, whose curve is slightly
less horrifying than Florida's, but still
really bad.
So what does Donald Trump do?
He decides he'll have a huge rally in Tulsa,
Oklahoma, because that's how you pretend things
are totally normal, except things aren't totally
normal.
And they know it because when you go to register
for tickets, you have to accept a waiver that
says if you catch coronavirus at the rally,
you will not hold Trump's campaign or the
event organizers responsible.
The exact wording is that by clicking register
below, you acknowledge that an inherent risk
of exposure to covert 19 exists in any public
space where people are present.
By attending the rally, you and any guests
voluntarily assume all risks related to exposure
to Kova 19 and agree not to hold Donald Trump
for president.
The be the Bok Center or anybody else liable
for illness or injury.
That sure doesn't sound like things are normal,
and that certainly doesn't sound like it's
the type of situation where you should be
having a huge rally.
Now, of course, Trump is protecting himself.
Trump's protecting his campaign.
But will he be protecting the people who are
there?
Will they hand out masks to everybody on the
way in and say where the mask during the rally?
Will they space people out so that they can
maintain some physical distance?
No, they appear.
The answer appears to be they're not going
to do any of those things when a rally needs
a medical warning label.
Maybe the rally shouldn't be happening.
Now, there's some very interesting sociology
and social psychology here.
We've talked about Trump ism as a cult.
And we've interviewed cult experts.
And this is sort of a test.
When Jim Jones had his cult down in Guyana,
he did a test run of having them drink cyanide
laced Kool-Aid where he didn't really put
the cyanide in the Kool-Aid.
This is where the term to drink the Kool-Aid
originated.
And the reason Jim Jones did this was to see
how devoted his cult followers were.
And then later on, he actually gave them the
cyanide laced Kool-Aid and 900 people died.
This is the Trump ism test.
Are you willing to go despite the waiver,
despite it obviously not being safe to do
an event this big in this crowded to pledge
your support for the deal?
Dear Leader.
Now, you might be wondering, what are right
wingers saying about this disclaimer?
I looked around.
A lot of them are saying, you liberal goons,
every big event is going to have a disclaimer
like this until we have a corona virus vaccine.
There's nothing special about a Trump rally
having this waiver.
What's special is that nobody else is having
events with 10000 people right now.
Other events might have a similar disclaimer
if they start having events this big, if it's
safe to start.
But there are no such events going on.
That's the whole point.
The fact that such a disclaimer is necessary
when you're the only people having an event
this big, that's a sign you shouldn't be having
the event at all.
Let me know what you think.
Remember, the David Pakman show chess tournament
is Tuesday, June 16th at 8:00 p.m..